We're about to play a brand-new
game called "Press & Guess."
Here we go.
-♪ Press, Press,
Press and Guess, yeah ♪
-Now I'm going to need someone
to play against.
She is the executive producer
of the HBO Max docuseries
"The Way Down: God, Greed,
and the Cult of Gwen Shamblin."
Give it up for Chrissy Teigen!
-♪ Press, Press,
Press and Guess ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Welcome!
-A new game?
-Alright. A new game.
-A new game.
-Alright. Here's how it works.
We're going to take turns
pressing our faces up
against this window here...
and saying a random phrase.
We have to get the other person
to guess the phrase
in 15 seconds.
If you have a window at home
where you can do this,
someone go outside, someone
stays in the living room.
We can make it work. 15 seconds.
Phrases are on the cards
right here.
Since you're my guest,
you are going to go first.
-Oh, great.
-Whenever -- Yeah, of course.
-This is the first and last time
you're going to do this.
-When you're ready,
take a look at your card
and then press your face
into the window
and try to get me
to guess the phrase.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. I'm going first?
-Yes. I'm not looking.
-Questlove has a good view
over there.
Okay.
-Are you ready?
-I mean, we didn't -- Okay.
We're just going to go for it?
-Yeah. Go for it.
-Like, pretty hard?
-Go for it.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. I forgot it. Okay.
[ Cymbal crash ]
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Spill -- Oh, no,
I couldn't say it, though.
My teeth go out too far.
[ Laughter ]
Why can't I --
-No, the other way was better.
-This way?
-Yeah.
[ Muffled ]
-"Change your teeth."
-[ Muffled ]
"Feel good teeth."
-"Feel."
[ Buzzer ]
-No! [ Laughs ]
-Feel the -- Feel the something?
Fill?
Spill the tea?
-Spill the tea.
-Spill the tea!
I would have gotten it!
[ Sad tuba ]
Darn.
Alright.
15 seconds is not quite enough.
Alright. Here we go.
Now it's my turn.
Oh, my gosh. You're going to
try to listen to it.
-It's hard! It's --
-Oh, my gosh.
-Teeth go out, so it's like --
-This is hard without
even pressing my face
against the glass.
-Have you tried this? Because
it's not -- it's not easy.
-Alright. Ready?
[ Laughter ]
[ Muffled ]
-What?!
-[ Muffled ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Muffled ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-What? What?!
[ Applause ]
-[ Muffled ]
I can't even do the first word.
[ Muffled ]
-Kids?
-[ Muffled ]
-Kids.
[ Muffled ]
-Si...
-[ Muffled ]
-Lids.
-Shins.
[ Laughter ]
-It was --
-No.
Pigs in a blanket! Wow!
-Alright. You are up.
You are up right now.
You can use this part.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-Alright, bud.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Muffled ]
-A key?
-Hakuna!
-Matata!
-Yeah!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes! We got one.
That's all we needed.
Okay. Okay.
Pay attention.
We got this. We got this.
-Okay.
♪♪
-[ Muffled ]
-Up, up, and away!
-Yes! Wow. Okay.
We are getting the hang of this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rasta horn blares ]
Okay.
You know what that sound means?
It's time for the bonus round.
To raise the stakes,
we both will be saying
the same phrase into the window,
trying to get Questlove
to guess what we are saying.
-Oh, boy. Alright.
-Let's take a look
at the final phrase.
Here we go.
-Okay.
Okay.
-Oh, gosh.
-Alright. Where do you want?
You can go there. I'll go here.
-Alright.
-Wait. I forgot.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. No. I got it. Okay.
-Yeah.
♪♪
[ Both muffled ]
[ Chrissy muffled ]
[ Jimmy muffled ]
-I spy a...
[ Both muffled ]
-I spy...
[ Chrissy muffled ]
[ Buzzer ]
-I -- I spy
with my little eye!
-The hell?
♪♪
[ Applause ]
-That was "Press & Guess."
The champion, Chrissy Teigen,
everybody.